let's get a look at the roads here at 8  o'clock with hector mejia good morning  hector hey there alex good morning we  have a tow truck finally on the scene of  this trouble spot in the east side look  at this we have a car flipped on its  side on northbound lanes of lamb just  after charleston  only one lane getting by but it looks  like it should be cleared soon as far as  the highway system goes we have the  the traffic there building up in the  usual spots the usual hot spots pretty  much everywhere and also  plan for this weekend closure starts  tonight southbound 95 ramp for  northbound i-15  have a wonderful friday and a better  weekend